[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH LANZET: All right.
Now let's bring up the
people that are behind that.
Let's start with co-creator
and executive producer Matthew
Federman.
Come on up.
Keep it going, guys.
Awesome.
We've got Sofia Pernas,
one of the stars.
Come on up here.
Matt Barr, another
wonderful star.
And another co-creator
and executive producer,
Steven Scaia.
Come on up, guys.
All right.
MATT BARR: Yes, I'm green.
Yes.
JOSH LANZET: Yeah
that's what we did.
We did it exclusively for you.
MATT BARR: That's
the OG Google color.
JOSH LANZET: Perfect.
Do we all like our colors?
Are we cool with
our colors here?
SOFIA PERNAS: With our colors.
JOSH LANZET: Perfect.
Wonderful.
STEVEN SCAIA: I'm-- I'm fine.
JOSH LANZET: You've got
your M&M's and you're good.
Good.
I do want you guys to know
that he goes to all of his
interviews with green M&M's.
That's how that works.
STEVEN SCAIA: Firm
contract rider.
JOSH LANZET: I believe that.
So let's get to-- let's
jump right in to that.
What was that?
A really boring drama, I think
that's what that was, right?
No action at all.
Let's start at the beginning.
Can you guys talk
me through kind
of the origins of this show?
How you guys came up with
it, how it came to be.
STEVEN SCAIA: Well it all
started because Matt and I,
we've been writing together
for quite some time.
And nearly every
development season, we
write a treasure hunter script.
And I think-- is this our
fourth or fifth crack at that?
MATTHEW FEDERMAN:
This is the fifth one,
and it's actually getting made.
STEVEN SCAIA: Right.
And so the difference
this time for us was we
discovered that ISIS's
second best form of revenue
was looting antiquities
and selling them
on the black market.
JOSH LANZET: Wow.
STEVEN SCAIA: And
so that gave us
a really good modern way in
to giving stakes to treasure.
When you don't have Nazis
and an Ark of the Covenant,
you've got to find a new way.
And that was a nice fresh take
and a way in that still had
very modern resonance, I think.
JOSH LANZET: Oh my gosh.
So you said, Nazis,
Ark of the Covenant.
So I have to ask,
having watched this.
Very Indiana Jones.
Very "Romancing the Stone."
Were those influences
for you guys
when you were writing this?
STEVEN SCAIA: Absolutely.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: Yeah
I mean, and it also
takes place in a world where
people have seen those things.
So they are
referenced because we
feel like it would
be weird for people
to be on a treasure
hunt in 2019 and not
be talking about Indiana
Jones all the time.
JOSH LANZET: I can just
imagine them being there,
being like, yeah,
this is like a movie.
I don't know what it was called.
Anyway.
Yeah, that would be--
that would be very, very odd.
But I think those--
I mean, we're talking
about movies right now.
We're not talking
about television.
This felt-- I know you guys
haven't watched the full show.
But you saw in the trailer, I
mean, it feels very cinematic.
Did you guys set out
to make something
that was a little more
movie-ish than TV?
STEVEN SCAIA: I think
for us, you know,
we've always been big
idea, very visual writers.
And when CBS wanted to do
a summer blockbuster on TV,
we were more than happy
to take them up on it.
And do something maybe
even a little different
for them that they were
excited about where
we didn't shoot in Atlanta.
We shot all over
the world instead.
And I think one of the things
we really like about the show
and what was really
fun with you guys
was, we went to those places.
We basically did our own stunts.
And we basically
didn't use green screen
unless we were maybe putting
a mountain in the background.
But anytime someone comes
through a skylight or rides
a motorcycle, that's a real
person doing the real thing.
It's not digital anything.
And it just--
I think you can
tell in the show,
it feels like a real adventure.
SOFIA PERNAS: Yeah
and how we were
able to shoot in
some of these places.
Like, you saw the
Trevi Fountain.
And we were right
outside the Vatican.
And I think it
was you, Matt, who
was like, I didn't even think
we would be able to do that.
I thought we'd have
to green screen that.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: It's really
funny because when we--
is this on, or not?
I can't tell.
JOSH LANZET: I think it is.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: OK.
SOFIA PERNAS: Just have to--
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: I've got to--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: When
we'd written that, which
was in 2016 at this point.
And we just wrote like, oh, we
should say something specific
that they walk past.
And then like, in some universe,
at least people will imagine
where they are in Italy.
But we're just clearly
never going to shoot there.
And then, everything about
this project just kept being us
saying, well they're
never going to do this.
But we might as well have
fun and just push it anyway.
And then like,
see if someone is,
you know, somehow dumb enough
to take us up on this thing.
STEVEN SCAIA: It's
the first project
we've worked on where it got
bigger and bigger and bigger
as you go along.
Because part of the
magic of television is,
do it faster and
spend less every time.
And everything we
came up with, it just
would keep getting larger
and larger and larger.
We weren't-- we weren't
originally going to Morocco.
Then all of a
sudden it was like,
hey how about Morocco
as well as Italy?
And then when we
got to Morocco, we
decided, hey, how about we
go to an whole other place
in Morocco?
Because it's got a completely
different visual feel.
And then it went from
foot chase to car chase.
And like, all
these little things
we would do along the way
when these guys were totally
game where they wanted
to crank it up too.
MATT BARR: Yeah,
and you know, there
was-- you would read
the scripts and think,
there is no way we can do this.
So you know-- and when
we'd arrive on set
and there was live cobras or
there was a zip line that's
going to catch on fire and
the whole half of the building
is going to fall
over, or, you know,
I'm going to be tied
to the top of a BMW.
And we would do it.
It was like, somehow these
guys and our whole team--
STEVEN SCAIA: I want
to feel like it's
because we were far enough
away from CBS headquarters
that they didn't quite
know what we were up to.
MATT BARR: No that's exact--
cause, yeah, when you're in the,
you know, the heart of Morocco,
you can get away with shit.
SOFIA PERNAS: Yeah, Barr
broke both his legs.
We have no idea how it happened.
We're going to make it work.
STEVEN SCAIA: Yeah.
MATT BARR: It was a
real cobra, you guys.
JOSH LANZET: I feel like
for the two of you, I mean,
you guys are probably
having scripts
sent to you all the time.
What was your initial
reaction when you read this?
I mean, this had to
have been crazy, right?
MATT BARR: I'll
take a step back.
I remember the press release
for this in like, 2017.
And there was like, CBS buys
series, "Blood and Treasure."
And I was like, oh my god.
That's going to be the
greatest show ever.
We were both doing other
shows at that time.
But, yeah.
I remember reading the script.
And as a boy that grew
up like every boy that
wants to be Indiana Jones,
and I thought, I'll be damned.
They did it.
Like, however they've
kind of captured
that magic, which I don't
know why no one seems to--
no one has done this.
I don't know.
It's like--
SOFIA PERNAS: Yeah well we both
have crazy casting stories.
Because specifically
because we both
fell in love with the script.
And so yes, I was on another
show at the same time.
But I was like, now I'm
getting on this show.
It's happening.
JOSH LANZET: Is
that how that works?
Is that you just
say, I'm getting on?
SOFIA PERNAS: I don't
care what I got to do.
MATT BARR: Who do
I have to kill?
SOFIA PERNAS: Who
do I have to kill?
Yeah, but it was nuts.
I mean, I think what?
You had 24 hours, then
you got on a plane.
And you were in--
you were in Montreal.
MATT BARR: Yeah.
STEVEN SCAIA: My two
favorite casting stories
are when she came in
to read for the part,
well she has an English
accent on the show.
And she came in, did the
whole thing, and left.
And we were like, was that?
Is she English?
This doesn't-- like, we had
no idea whether it was a put
on or whether it was real.
Because you stayed in
it the entire time.
It was brilliant.
SOFIA PERNAS: First of all,
I don't remember doing that.
I don't remember.
STEVEN SCAIA: You don't
remember not doing it either.
SOFIA PERNAS: I don't
So, who knows?
MATT BARR: She
actually is English.
This is all an act.
STEVEN SCAIA: But
then, then when
we called this guy to tell
him he got the job, you could,
like, the scream was so
loud that the phone actually
shorted out.
And then it stopped.
And he's like, OK guys.
What do I need to do?
And we're like,
don't worry about it.
We just need you to get
on a plane tomorrow.
And he's like, ha ha ha.
No seriously, when
do I need to go?
We're like, no Matt.
We start shooting on Wednesday.
Then it got really quiet.
MATT BARR: Pack
for seven months.
STEVEN SCAIA: Yeah.
JOSH LANZET: So you
packed for seven months
in less than 12 hours?
MATT BARR: I really did.
JOSH LANZET: Oh my--
SOFIA PERNAS: Like, I'll
just buy my closet--
MATT BARR: The good
thing is, you know,
I probably own three jeans
and a few t-shirts and--
JOSH LANZET: A lot of
linen and flip flops.
MATT BARR: Yeah, a couple
flip-flops and, you know,
I'm good to go.
JOSH LANZET: So you can
take the boy out of Texas.
That's pretty much
what you're saying.
MATT BARR: That's right.
JOSH LANZET: Got it.
So, so OK.
So you guys, you
got the scripts.
I mean, was it a very
long process for you
two, kind of starting
from reading it
to being cast in this?
SOFIA PERNAS: Well, what
made mine a little bit crazy
was because I was on
another show at the time.
JOSH LANZET: Oh wow.
SOFIA PERNAS: And so it was
a very interesting needle
to thread, that one.
JOSH LANZET: I'm sensing some
withholding, which is great.
I'm fine with it.
STEVEN SCAIA: I think it's
that we all knew she was cast
and she knew she was cast.
But the world could not
know she was cast yet.
Until the fate of
that show was decided.
SOFIA PERNAS: Yes, the fate
of the show had to be decided.
STEVEN SCAIA: And we
had contingency plans.
But still.
SOFIA PERNAS: Yeah.
STEVEN SCAIA: Yeah.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN:
Our contingency plan
was to end that other show.
We were like, she's
literally the only person
in the world that
can do this part.
So whatever we have to do,
whoever we have to kill,
just let us know.
MATT BARR: What I'll
say is pretty cool
is like, it's rare when you
read a script that you just love
and you think, I'm
born to play this part.
And very rarely does that
align with your reality.
And when it does, it's like
a freaking miracle, you know?
So it was fun that
when this worked out,
and I joined this team,
that thought I'm like,
walking in my dreams right now.
STEVEN SCAIA: And I think that
that's what's great about them
in the show is, we cast them
as actors to play parts.
But you guys are so very
much those people on screen
that we wrote before
we even met you.
You guys are the perfect
people for those roles.
Because there are so many
times we'd be somewhere,
and you would say
or do something,
or you would say
or do something.
And we're like, that's
such a Lexi thing.
So Lexi.
It's so Danny.
JOSH LANZET: Well so when
did you two first meet?
Did you meet on set?
Or did you have a
chemistry read beforehand?
SOFIA PERNAS: Well, technically,
we had met January of 2018.
Because we were both on
military shows at the time.
MATT BARR: At a veteran's event.
SOFIA PERNAS: We met
at a veteran awards
ceremony promoting each
other's military shows.
Then six months
later, we were doing--
he calls me and he
goes, hey, we met.
And I'm chemistry reading
with you tomorrow.
And I was like, oh no sh--
no shit.
JOSH LANZET: My favorite
thing is, you said it.
Then you looked around.
And then you said it again.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: That was peak
Sofia you just saw right there.
That's why she's so Lexi.
MATT BARR: It's cool cause
at that veteran's event--
at that event when
I met Sofia, we
were both doing
this veterans thing.
I remember thinking like, this
is the kind of actress I like.
One, what a cool human being.
But two, we talked
about work and sort
of how we approached
being actors.
And I was like, this
is the perfect balance.
Like, I would love
to get in a foxhole
with an actor like this.
And so we, you know, just
thought, good luck to you,
you know?
And I hope I get to
work with you one day.
And then three months
later, we were--
SOFIA PERNAS: We were
literally in a foxhole.
Yeah.
MATT BARR: Literally
in a burning--
burning foxhole.
JOSH LANZET: I mean, I
haven't seen that episode.
But I can't wait.
It sounds great.
So this show jumps everywhere,
all over geographically,
all over the world.
When you two were
writing it, was
part of the allure
to essentially take
the audience on a free trip
with you all around the world?
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: Yeah because
I-- lots of times the way
we split it up is Steve is
running the set, basically,
and I'm running
the writers room.
And then we kind of cross--
we cross over.
And sometimes I would
be in the writers room
and we'd be working
on the story.
And then Steve would come in
and we would pitch him a thing.
And he'd be like, wait, where?
We're just in like, one city?
And I'm like, well we're
figuring out the story.
No no.
We got to-- we got
to-- we got to go here.
We'll go to-- we'll
go to Montreal here,
and we'll go to here.
You know, he just like,
starts throwing cities up
on the board.
I'm like, OK.
Get out of the room until
we figure out the story.
But it was definitely
the point was that it
should feel like a travelogue.
We would joke, it's
Anthony Bourdain with guns.
But it's like, it should feel
like these beautiful parts
of the world.
And the audience
is on an adventure,
you know, as much with
us as the characters.
STEVEN SCAIA: Yeah,
I think for us,
we've always loved traveling.
And so to be able
to-- for us to be
able to go and see these places,
but also present them in a way
that you would want
to go to them too.
And so, when we go
to a refugee camp,
it's a sexy refugee
camp by the beach.
You know?
Like, you really get
the sense of this
is a world that you want to
get out there and explore.
And I think for us,
one of the fun things
was finding those places
in Morocco and Italy.
I mean, Italy's easy because,
I mean, look at that.
Who wouldn't want to go there?
But there's so many
places in the world
that you wouldn't
necessarily think of,
this would be a
great place to visit.
But you go and we show that.
And I think hopefully
it'll get people out
of their houses a
little bit more.
JOSH LANZET: Ah.
So you were trying
to encourage travel?
I get it.
That makes sense.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: We're
actually a travel agency
that's, you know, working
the long way around
on our business.
STEVEN SCAIA: Yeah.
JOSH LANZET: Oh perfect.
Well I'm sold.
I'm ready to go wherever
that picture was taken.
This was filmed across what?
Three continents?
Is that right?
STEVEN SCAIA: That's true.
JOSH LANZET: So what was it like
for-- have you guys ever been
on shows where you were
traveling as much as you
traveled for this?
MATT BARR: No.
It was awesome.
SOFIA PERNAS: It was nuts.
MATT BARR: Yeah.
It was fun to, like, go to
sleep in the Italian Alps,
and then wake up in Morocco.
And you're in some
Medina with camels.
JOSH LANZET: I hope you
know that no one can
say that sentence.
Like there are like, maybe
five people that have
said that sentence before.
STEVEN SCAIA: I've never had
a job where the call to prayer
was my alarm in the morning.
And that was pretty special.
SOFIA PERNAS: Yup.
MATT BARR: Yeah.
SOFIA PERNAS: Yeah.
It was-- I'm from--
I was born in Morocco.
So I've now had the honor of
twice in a row shooting there.
But this one was like,
very, we shot all over.
So it was great.
I was like the secret
Moroccan on set.
Because apparently I don't look
Moroccan, is what I was told.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN:
That's a weird--
SOFIA PERNAS: Cause
I speak the language.
JOSH LANZET: I was going to
say, that's a new script,
is Secret Moroccan.
SOFIA PERNAS: Secret Moroccan.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: Can
you find the Moroccan?
JOSH LANZET: It's like
a new Where's Waldo?
I'm excited.
Was the travel-- I imagine
travel might be a little easier
for you because you
speak, I want to say,
is it four languages?
Yeah.
So it might have
been easier for you.
And Matt, I think
you're cracking one?
MATT BARR: That's right.
JOSH LANZET: It's like--
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: He's
got a couple more classes.
And then he's totally
going to be there.
MATT BARR: Sofia's dad
won the Nobel Peace Prize.
Matt's dad mows the
yard on Sundays.
JOSH LANZET: You know,
and mowing the yard
is a peaceful thing
that deserves a prize.
STEVEN SCAIA: And
he's great at it.
MATT BARR: Yeah, but
he's great at it, guys.
STEVEN SCAIA: He like, puts
the pattern on it, you know?
JOSH LANZET: I've always been
impressed with your father.
I want you to know that.
MATT BARR: Thank you.
JOSH LANZET: But in
terms of all this travel,
I imagine some things
didn't go as planned, right?
There had to have been--
nothing ever goes
perfectly, especially when
you're running three
continents in the mix.
Any stories of things that
kind of didn't go so hot?
STEVEN SCAIA: I mean, the
two stories that come to mind
are Colosseum Night.
And then the day in
the Medina in Tangier.
Where we were
shooting a chase scene
through the streets of
Tangier, doubling for Havana--
which, by the way, I
just said that sentence,
and it sounds awesome.
And that day, it poured
rain all morning long.
And we were in
two inches of rain
in the middle of this Medina.
We had like, 200 extras.
It was a big day.
And it didn't stop
raining for the first four
hours of the day.
So we just lost a
whole bunch of time.
The sun finally came out, but we
had lost the ability to shoot.
Because we were at the
end of the schedule,
and we were out of
things to shoot that
weren't basically action
scenes set in a Medina.
And we were out
of space to do it.
So we were sitting there.
It was me and the
director, Steve Boyum.
And we were trying
to figure out, OK,
what can we do here
when the sun goes down?
Because we've got
to keep shooting.
Because we've got-- we've got
basically three days left.
But we've got eight pages
still left to shoot.
And the only thing
left on the schedule
that we hadn't shot yet
that we meant to pick up
in other places, but it kept
dropping off of our schedule,
was this little
moment in Episode 2
where they parachute
into a place
and they roll over
in a parachute.
And we had this Medina set.
And we had, like, was it two
eighths of a page of you guys
landing in a parachute
and rolling over.
And so we decided, OK.
All we need to do
is we need someone
to go out and find us like,
four feet square of AstroTurf.
And we can shoot this scene
in the middle of the Medina.
We did that.
But then we also
didn't realize by doing
that in the middle of the
Medina in Tangier, which is--
it's a safe place.
But you know, you try not
to get people riled up.
But they were-- some
people were very displeased
that we had a man and
a woman rolling around
in a parachute in the
middle of a Medina.
So it got to be a very--
it was a very interesting night.
But I'll never forget.
You look at the cut of the
episode, and you don't realize,
oh we shot that like, this far
away from a lamb on a spit.
When a romantic
scene of you guys
rolling around on AstroTurf.
Yeah.
SOFIA PERNAS: Yeah.
That was nuts.
JOSH LANZET: From
a lamb on a spit?
STEVEN SCAIA: Yeah
because that's
part of the other episode.
JOSH LANZET: Oh.
Of course.
Obviously.
I don't know why I
didn't think that.
STEVEN SCAIA: We had to take
the stand that we were shooting,
this sort of like-- it
was like a market set.
We stripped it down, stapled
the four feet of AstroTurf
that our prop guy
had found somewhere
in the streets of Morocco,
brought it back, set it up--
SOFIA PERNAS: And every time
I would rest my head on what
I thought was just
beautiful, lush grass,
there would be a needle
in the back of my head.
Where he stapled the AstroTurf.
And I'd be like, Matt,
just let me down easy, OK?
Just let me down easy.
I don't want a lobotomy today.
JOSH LANZET: Now you said there
was something at the Colosseum?
STEVEN SCAIA: Yeah.
So we got to shoot
outside the Colosseum.
And it was this
amazing location.
There's this park overlooking
the Colosseum that's--
I've never seen it in a
movie or a TV show before.
But it's this amazing-- it's
like a dog park in Rome.
Because they don't care.
It's just like, this is
where we walk our dog.
MATT BARR: It's incredible.
STEVEN SCAIA: Whatever.
And so we had
locked the location.
And we were going to
shoot it the next day
where Danny and
Father Chuck were
going to have a nice scene.
MATT BARR: I just remember
we had lost that location.
And the next day,
we had had it back.
And I was like, our
producer, Irene, I said--
yeah.
I said, how did you swing it?
She goes, she goes,
don't ask me that.
Just continue with your day.
Shit.
STEVEN SCAIA: And that
was the kind of thing
we were up against
the entire time
where, I guess the mayor
of Rome had declared
that all public
parks in the district
were closed because it was
the worst weather they'd
had in six years.
And all of the old
trees were falling down.
But we were happy to go in and,
you know, take the trees out,
clean it up for them.
Like guys, we'll leave that park
nicer than when we got there.
And they're like, no.
Za parks, they're all closed.
And--
MATT BARR: He's
Italian, by the way.
So it's offensive--
JOSH LANZET: Spot
on It was spot on.
STEVEN SCAIA: But
I will say, I don't
know what happened overnight.
I just know that maybe--
you know what?
I'm not going to say.
I'm not going to guess.
Because I still want to be--
I want to be welcomed back
to Italy for Season 2.
I just know that--
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: Persuasive
people made their case.
STEVEN SCAIA: It
got taken care of.
JOSH LANZET: I mean, I just--
I hope you're hearing
these sentences.
The mayor of Rome said no,
and then all of a sudden,
he said yes.
I don't think people
say that ever.
STEVEN SCAIA: It's
definitely-- it's
a different experience than
shooting in Simi Valley,
I will say.
JOSH LANZET: And you know what?
I think the show
could've worked there.
Can I say that?
I don't--
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: Season 3.
JOSH LANZET: Yeah, as I
was watching, I was like,
let's get this to
Toronto or Atlanta.
That's where this could be.
Were there any challenges for
the two of you in all of this
travel?
Any kind of things
you didn't see coming?
SOFIA PERNAS: Not dying.
MATT BARR: Not dying.
SOFIA PERNAS: That's
my nice answer.
MATT BARR: We snuck off
to Pasitano for like,
a couple days when we
had our probably two days
off the whole shoot we had.
And, you know, the trains,
like, finding your way
around is kind of tough.
So we wound up in,
like, another city.
As you would.
And then had to find the train
to get there and then take a,
you know, a van to another
city to get a little taxi
to the place we were going to.
So that was fun getting lost.
SOFIA PERNAS: But during
shooting, do you remember?
I don't even remember.
It's like, I was wiped.
STEVEN SCAIA: My
favorite part about that
was you guys pretending like
you weren't getting hurt.
Like, it was-- look,
it was grueling.
The days were long.
And there was a lot of running
around, no matter where
we were in the world.
And each of them would
pull that move where,
it was your knee and your leg.
They would show up on
set a little bit limpy.
And they'd be like,
nah, it's fine.
Let's do this.
Let's do it.
It's fine.
SOFIA PERNAS: I like this
just hanging off of my hip.
STEVEN SCAIA: I just need a
little ice and about 15 Advil.
We'll do it.
It's like they were
like old stunt men
by the time we were
done with this thing.
MATT BARR: I remember thinking
I was hiding that well.
STEVEN SCAIA: No, you
were terrible at it.
SOFIA PERNAS: There was
one-- there was one day where
we were in the Medina.
I had no idea how Stephen Boyum.
Did it.
Well not-- well he was
a director of ours.
But anyway, so it was packed.
It was crazy.
And then I'm
pouring tea with one
of our castmates, Katja Winter.
And it's like, you
know, a long pour tea.
And then all of a sudden,
you just hear screaming.
From nowhere.
And I was like, wait,
that's not us, is it?
That's not-- that's
not-- there's no way.
And then we look over.
And there's just a
riot breaking out.
And Matt-- I think you're
in the middle of it.
Well, you were
shooting your scene.
MATT BARR: Yeah.
JOSH LANZET: I was
taking a break.
And I was like, this is
what happens when I leave.
A riot.
A riot breaks out.
But it was nuts.
MATT BARR: I just
thought the people who
were directing the extras
was like, doing a great job.
Like, look at these
guys-- these kids are--
STEVEN SCAIA: Use it!
SOFIA PERNAS: Clamoring.
MATT BARR: Everyone's
so into this.
JOSH LANZET: And
all of a sudden,
a riot appeared in the script.
And it all made sense.
STEVEN SCAIA: Looks great.
JOSH LANZET: No, I'm sure.
STEVEN SCAIA: You can't--
you can't pay for that.
JOSH LANZET: Certainly not.
So, you were saying
that they got injured.
So there were a lot
of stunts in this.
Were you doing most
of your own stunts?
MATT BARR: Yeah.
Yeah.
SOFIA PERNAS: We were.
But the really cool stuff, my
stunt double, Zandara Kennedy.
I mean, that girl is just--
she's an Avenger.
Ii mean, she was going
150 miles on a Ducati.
And there's no way.
CBS was like, you won't even
go two miles on a motorcycle.
But Zandara-- of course
her name's Zandara.
So.
JOSH LANZET: Sure.
That makes sense.
MATT BARR: Sofia's being
pretty modest, really.
This girl really-- she
is like half ninja.
I mean, she knows martial arts.
She handled-- she
did a military show,
so she knows weaponry well.
And it's like, I
mean, I'll be damned
if she can't do everything that,
you know, they want her to do.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN:
There was one night
where we had a big fight
scene, in 103, that big fight
scene in the tea thing.
And we were like--
they said, like, we had like,
five hours of shooting left,
but like, an hour
to shoot it in.
And every one of them had a
fight scene within that fight
scene that-- because
it was basically
four of them going to battle
against the entire room
full of people.
And every one of them,
you watch Matt go in.
And he just like, nails this
really complicated fight
with five guys at the same time.
And a hookah pipe that
breaks in the middle of it.
And it was like, wow.
He nailed that.
And then, OK.
Let's do it again.
He nails it again.
It was like, oh.
And then he comes back.
He's like, did my part.
And then she's like, all right.
I'm going in.
One after another,
they just all went in
and they just nailed it.
And it's like, wow, this
show would really not
be makeable without
this group of people,
if you had, you know,
any other set of actors.
STEVEN SCAIA: I think
our directors were always
surprised because they
would read the scripts
and see how ambitious they were.
And then they would show up like
a good guest director trying
to make it easier.
And we'd be like, no, no, no.
That's not "Blood and Treasure."
We have to make this harder.
And they would get into it.
And then they would see these
guys on set thinking, OK so,
we'll use the stunt doubles
for all of the big action.
We'll punch in for
some close ups.
And we would just laugh and
be like, sure, sure, sure.
Why don't we just do one run
through with our actors first?
Just sort of like,
just to warm them up.
And they'd see you guys do it at
full speed, completely capable.
And then they would just look
at the two stunt, you know,
the two stunt people, and
be like, Robert and Zandara,
you guys can just hang
here for a minute.
And then they would just
sit in costume and chairs
while you guys did the
entire thing yourselves.
SOFIA PERNAS: It was fun.
It was fun.
It was also like, there was
one fight scene where it
was, you know, girl and girl.
We were just going at it.
It was-- well--
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: Language.
JOSH LANZET: All right.
I love just watching
Matt's face during that.
He went on a journey.
STEVEN SCAIA: This
show has everything.
SOFIA PERNAS: You guys,
please watch 21st.
But yeah, it was a really
intense fight scene.
And I remember the stunt
double I was fighting.
Her name was [INAUDIBLE].
She was a ninja.
But there was-- it starts off
with her doing this flying
kick at me.
And she's like, I don't
know how to sell this.
Because it's a kick in mid
air and I'm hitting you.
I was like, just kick me.
Just do it.
And she was like, are you sure?
I was like, just do it.
We have no time.
And then she kicked me.
And I was like, oh my god.
You like, drove the--
the lungs-- just the
air out of my body.
But and then it was a
five minute fight scene.
STEVEN SCAIA: By the
way, that's in the cut,
because it looks awesome.
SOFIA PERNAS: She's
a tae kwon do champ.
I can tell you.
Yeah.
MATT BARR: There's a
scene where I'm giving--
I'm stabbing Sofia in
the arm with a little--
I don't want to say too much.
A little thing to save her life.
And so, you know, I--
MATTHEW FEDERMAN:
Well if you say less,
it's going to
actually be weirder--
MATT BARR: Yeah.
That's right.
Yeah.
That's what we're trying to do.
STEVEN SCAIA: Guys this
show has everything.
JOSH LANZET: It's in the pilot.
MATT BARR: So like,
after 10 takes,
you know, it's a
fake thing, right?
So I'm just-- I'm doing the arm.
And then I, you know, I look,
and her arm is just like,
it was like, 10 puncture
wounds and blood on her arm.
And I thought, oh my god.
Have I been doing that to you?
And she's like, yes.
Every time.
I was, you know, I thought
you were committed.
So I didn't want to mess
with your process there.
But.
SOFIA PERNAS: It was like, the
first thing of our partnership.
He was like, why
didn't you tell me?
I was like, I don't want
to break your focus.
MATT BARR: I think you
still have scars on your arm
from that.
SOFIA PERNAS: Where this was
just a thin trail of blood.
JOSH LANZET: I don't think I'd
be speaking to him after that.
I don't know.
MATT BARR: We all
bleed for our art.
JOSH LANZET: He's
a charming guy.
SOFIA PERNAS: Just committing
right in the shoulder
every time.
Like, damn.
Damn.
OK.
JOSH LANZET: So I know that
you, Sofia, you did "The Brave."
You did "Operation Rogue."
So you already had some
kind of gun training
and military training.
Did you go through
extra training for this?
SOFIA PERNAS: I
mean, very briefly.
Gun Guy Brent.
STEVEN SCAIA: Yeah,
mostly we just
wanted to fool around with guns.
And so they took us out.
SOFIA PERNAS: --fool
around with guns.
But I think they saw
really quickly that we
weren't just like, oh guns!
You know, we're obviously,
we know gun safety
and we were not being lax with
any kind of firearms on set.
So we just got to
be able to play.
And so that was what it was.
I mean, we went--
I think both-- did
you do the gun thing
too out in the Montreal farm?
MATT BARR: No I
don't think I did.
JOSH LANZET: Matt's from Texas.
He doesn't-- Matt
wasn't invited,
MATT BARR: I don't
think I was hired yet.
STEVEN SCAIA: That is true.
SOFIA PERNAS: Yeah, that's true.
But yeah.
He just-- it was crazy.
Like, there was
this random farm out
in the boons,
boonies in Montreal.
And this guy had an
arsenal, like an actual--
I was like, are you
preparing for war?
What is happening?
But it was a vault
just lined with guns.
And he was like,
pick whichever one.
He had like, World War II--
he had every kind of weapon
there was in there.
And then, I shot some, and
he's like, you're good.
All right.
You're off.
And that was it.
STEVEN SCAIA: There was
nothing more satisfying
than getting the report
back from all the department
heads about how competent and
unactor-like you guys were.
Where I'd be like, the stunt guy
would come back after training.
He's like, they're good.
They're going to be fine.
The gun guy would come back,
[INAUDIBLE] like, they're good.
They're going to be fine.
Like, every step of the
way, costume is like, oh,
everything looks good on them.
It's like, we might
just pull this off.
MATT BARR: Sofia can shoot
a gun, drop the clip,
grab the other clip, put
it back in, shoot it again,
like kill shot.
And then put it
back in her holster.
And you're like,
don't mess with here.
STEVEN SCAIA: Oh, and
also, super hyper real girl
over here.
We're always cutting
around-- what do you call it?
The press check?
That you do every time
you pick up a gun.
Because she can't help it
because of her training.
SOFIA PERNAS: Well when you make
it sound like that, Stephen,
I am not obnoxious.
JOSH LANZET: Wait, so
what is the press check?
SOFIA PERNAS: Well
on "The Brave--"
"The Brave" was
this military show.
But the guy who was
our technical advisor
was an ex Navy SEAL.
So if we--a press
check is sort of like--
you guys have all seen
"John Wick," right?
Well Keanu Reeves does
a press check every time
before he shoots.
And everybody, like, Navy
SEALs and operator guys
go absolutely nuts
over Keanu Reeves
because he's so
authentic and he's real.
So if we didn't
do a press check,
our advisor would
make us beat a wheel--
a tire with a sledgehammer.
You're supposed to make sure
there's a round in the chamber.
STEVEN SCAIA: When you
pick up a bad guy's gun.
MATT BARR: You had to say Keanu.
STEVEN SCAIA: Yeah.
It's fucking awesome.
SOFIA PERNAS: You
check the mag, make
sure there's a round in the
chamber before you shoot.
Otherwise, maybe there's a,
you know, the gun doesn't work.
And then you're screwed.
JOSH LANZET: Sorry I just want
to back up just a smidge there.
Did you say something about
a sledgehammer and a wheel?
SOFIA PERNAS: A tire.
A tire.
JOSH LANZET: A tire.
What?
SOFIA PERNAS: Yeah,
it was his way, like,
if we didn't have our mags
out and the gun on safety,
we weren't practicing regular,
you know, safety regulations.
So he would pick up the
weighted sledgehammer
and beat the tire
until he said--
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: Is
that a SAG approved--
SOFIA PERNAS: No.
It was good.
That's what we needed.
That's how we
didn't die that day.
Because there were
some un actor like--
STEVEN SCAIA: That's very true.
SOFIA PERNAS: --actors
on the range that day.
JOSH LANZET: Yeah I love
how these three are like,
oh yeah, yeah.
Sledgehammer.
Tire.
Makes sense.
I'm like, what?
STEVEN SCAIA: It's
how they learn.
JOSH LANZET: Yeah.
Oh obviously.
That's how I learn, most times.
Any time I'm dating someone,
if I do something wrong,
she always have me go out
back just with a sledgehammer
and the tire.
STEVEN SCAIA: Yeah chop
some wood, yeah, exactly.
JOSH LANZET: Now I know,
Matt, for you, you've
had gun training as well.
I also believe you've
been on horses.
Are we going to see
any horseback riding
in the first season of
"Blood and Treasure?"
MATT BARR: You bet
your ass you are.
JOSH LANZET: Yes.
STEVEN SCAIA: You've got to
tell that story about how like,
day one, he gets here, and he's
like, so we're doing horses,
right?
And we're like, we don't have
any horses in the episode.
MATT BARR: But Stephen,
every adventure show or movie
has horses.
You've got to have
the horses there.
Need to see it.
SOFIA PERNAS: 100%.
STEVEN SCAIA: He slowly wore
us down to the point where--
that day-- it was--
that was maybe my
finest moment, with you,
of being able to be like,
Matt, I got greatness.
MATT BARR: I was like, we need
horses and we need quicksand.
And they're like, well I
can get you the horses.
STEVEN SCAIA:
Quicksand Season 2.
MATT BARR: Season 2.
JOSH LANZET: Wait, so
the horses weren't in it.
Matt just comes in
with his Texas style
and you go, all right, horses.
We'll do horses.
SOFIA PERNAS: Well that's what's
so awesome about these two guys
here.
Because I mean,
Stephen at one point
was going around set
like taking a poll,
being like, hey, coolest
thing you ever want to do,
tell me, bucket list.
Do it.
Right now.
And I'm like, laser dance.
He's like, Season 2.
It's happening.
STEVEN SCAIA: But
you were double guns.
SOFIA PERNAS: I was double guns.
And you made it happen.
STEVEN SCAIA: We made it happen.
SOFIA PERNAS: You
made it happen.
JOSH LANZET: Did
you say laser dance?
SOFIA PERNAS: Yeah.
You know, in every show, like--
MATT BARR: Trying
to entrapment here.
SOFIA PERNAS: Entrapment.
JOSH LANZET: Oh entrapment.
SOFIA PERNAS: "Oceans 11,"
there's a laser dance.
JOSH LANZET: I didn't know
it was called a laser dance.
SOFIA PERNAS: Laser-- yeah.
Well it is a dance.
JOSH LANZET: OK.
SOFIA PERNAS: But
I mean, you know?
JOSH LANZET: I'm going
to take your word for it.
No sure.
We all know.
So--
SOFIA PERNAS: Stephen
was taking bucket lists.
And then he would report back.
And then Matt's like, OK.
He would approve.
And then somehow, it
would be on the script.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: Yeah I
just get very strange calls
from Steve where we're
in the middle of like,
trying to break 110.
And it's like, OK.
So we need-- we
need horses for 106.
So do you see any place
where we can have horses?
And it's like, what?
After a while, I would
just stop asking why.
I would just be like, OK,
let me get back to you
and we'll see if this--
MATT BARR: Stephen's like,
Matt wants an electric eel.
I was like-- sorry,
we can't do that.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: Every
now and then, it actually
solves a story problem.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MATT BARR: But they're
cool, you guys.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MATT BARR: The treasure
is behind the eel.
JOSH LANZET: I would
never want that.
Your list is much
stranger than yours.
Yours is like lasers
and double guns.
SOFIA PERNAS: I had
a very reasonable--
I was like, Stephen, I just want
to shoot two guns in this show.
At one point, I want
a pistol in each hand.
And then in like
Episode 10, it happens,
where I'm reading the script--
he could--
JOSH LANZET: We won't say
why she's using the guns.
SOFIA PERNAS: He
would never tell me
it was happening for sure.
So when I read the
script and it's like,
Lexi looks at the second gun,
I was like, no, you didn't!
And then I was
like, yes you did!
It was crazy.
It was like, you
guys are magicians.
It's like, you think
it, and so it is so.
STEVEN SCAIA: But like,
I feel like that's
the fun of the show, right?
It's like, the shit that
you can think of that
would be really cool
to do, it's like, yeah.
Let's just put that on TV.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: Are
we allowed to curse?
Or is we just doing that?
STEVEN SCAIA: It's Google.
They'll take it out.
JOSH LANZET: I mean, if it was--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOSH LANZET: If it wasn't
allowed, it is now.
You know, that's
kind of where-- we've
passed-- we passed
that, I think,
with Sofia, like 30 minutes ago.
So we're good.
Was there anything
else on your list?
It was just-- it was
just horses for you?
MATT BARR: Oh, I had a
list of like 375 things.
We got through about
20 of them I'd say.
STEVEN SCAIA: Yeah yeah.
JOSH LANZET: Oh good.
Good, good, good.
STEVEN SCAIA: Matt's list
is the most comprehensive
of everyone's.
But also it's good,
because like I
said, like the quick
sand is like, that's
a great target for Season 2.
JOSH LANZET: Sure.
MATT BARR: I'll
keep them coming.
JOSH LANZET: I don't doubt it.
MATT BARR: We need sharks
too, at some point.
We need sharks.
JOSH LANZET: I don't
want to be your friend.
Very scared of you.
I mean, for you, just, I want to
know your mindset for a second.
You've played a gunslinger.
You've played a
helicopter pilot.
You've now played an Indiana
Jones like character.
You are living the dream of
every young boy everywhere.
Are you just one superhero
movie away from just retiring?
MATT BARR: I think so.
I mean, you know, growing up on
"Top Gun" and "Indiana Jones,"
I've done both of those.
So.
JOSH LANZET: Yeah.
MATT BARR: I don't know.
Maybe.
JOSH LANZET: Yeah I like,
looked at your roles,
and I was like, OK.
Well he's living my dreams.
That's fine, OK.
Reasonable.
Yeah, I'm not jealous.
Sofia, for you-- because I don't
want to talk to him anymore.
You play, I guess, I don't know
how-- a lovable con artist?
I don't know what the right
term would be for that.
STEVEN SCAIA: Master thief.
JOSH LANZET: A master thief.
SOFIA PERNAS:
Yeah, master thief.
I steal everything,
not just art.
Emphasis on art, I guess.
But I steal, you know, jewels.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: But
also in real life too.
JOSH LANZET: You
steal people's hearts.
SOFIA PERNAS: Don't
leave your things out.
I steal hearts.
JOSH LANZET: There you go.
SOFIA PERNAS: That's what I do.
Aw.
JOSH LANZET: Did you--
did you do any specific
training or preparation
to play, like a thief?
SOFIA PERNAS: I stole Matt's
sunglasses at the audition.
That was how I got the role.
No, I'm kidding.
I'm totally joking.
No.
I have not practiced
any of those things.
Just guns.
JOSH LANZET: Just guns.
Exclusively guns.
MATT BARR: Hey, Sofia.
This is actually an
intervention for you.
This is all just a--
it's OK.
Let it out.
SOFIA PERNAS:
Speaking of things,
there is no bowler
hat scene in Season 1.
There should be.
I mean, come on.
Season 2.
JOSH LANZET: I mean, one of my
favorite scenes from any movie.
The bowler hat scene.
Incredible.
Absolutely incredible.
I have more
questions, but I also
want to make sure that
we get to the audience.
Does anyone in the audience
have any questions?
We do have one over here.
We're bringing a mic to you.
SPEAKER 6: This is a mic?
SOFIA PERNAS: Yeah.
STEVEN SCAIA: It is a
cartoonishly large mic, yes.
SPEAKER 6: OK, here we go.
So you know, it
looks really cool.
It seems like it's very like a
comedy, action, drama, romance,
Chinese restaurant
resort and everything.
I wonder, will you folks be
doing some sort of like, more
comedy on putting the action
adventure troops on its head,
you know?
Like the whole storm
troopers always failing
to actually hit their targets?
Or having some comedy part of
that of the usual adventure
troupes of Indiana Jones and
all these movies that you are--
STEVEN SCAIA: Yeah
I mean, I think
because like we were
saying, the show takes place
in a world where we
literally reference Indiana
Jones, "Predator,"
"Die Hard," like,
all those movies that you'd
love if you loved the show.
And so it gives
you a chance to be
able to not just
take those moments
and turn them on their head.
But actually
acknowledge the moment
when you're doing something
from one of those movies.
Two characters can look
at be like, oh my god.
We're totally doing this
thing from that thing.
It's like, oh my god.
This is awesome.
And I think it is really fun
because it feels like people
I'd want to hang out with.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN:
Yeah I think for us,
the trick is like, if it ever
becomes so meta that it's goofy
and that it's like you're not
watching the show anymore.
You're watching us all making
a show, you know what I mean?
Like, then we don't
want to go that far.
But we want to go far
enough where if literally
you were in this
situation, wouldn't you
bring up "Die Hard" right now?
Like, wouldn't-- you
know what I mean?
It's like we all--
because it's partially a
show about culture and things
like that as art
and antiquities are.
And pop culture is
a part of culture.
So it's like, it's the way
we all talk to each other.
And their characters--
Lexi like, doesn't know
any of his references.
Because she grew up
around the world.
She wasn't, you know, so
it's like, the pop culture
references in the show actually
serve another purpose of like,
being able to talk about
culture in a different way
and all that kind of stuff.
So I think when we're
deconstructing the genre,
we're deconstructing
it like modernize it,
but we're not deconstructing
it so far that it
feels like it falls apart.
SPEAKER 6: I do follow before.
So now concerning talking
that you folks are--
you mentioned about, oh we
want to use, like, you know,
right now, sort of ISIS
as a model of they're
dealing with art, and you
know, before the Nazis.
There's no Nazis anymore.
Do we plan to then
maybe for other seasons
use other sort of like, the
narcos in Latin America?
Or warlords in Africa?
And like, making it a
little more diverse,
and less just, you
know, Islam, bad.
And stuff like that.
STEVEN SCAIA: That's exactly how
we think about the show, which
is in success, were we
did do more seasons,
we would pick a different
part of the world with it
maybe a different treasure,
different bad guys.
And they would want
a different thing.
But I think that like any good
summer novel or blockbuster
in the franchise
of it, we want you
to be able to look at the visual
and know, oh this is a Season 2
episode.
This is a Season 3 episode.
Because of where they
are in the world.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN:
And we also the--
when we pitched the show, we
were talking about how like,
in real life, there's guys with
AK-47s in parts of the world
like, you know, the
ancient city of Palmyra
was blown up by ISIS.
So those guys that went in
there, they killed people.
They cut stuff out.
They put it on a truck.
Then they blow up
the rest of the stuff
that they can't
move for PR value.
They're like, look.
We're the guys who
did this thing.
Then all that stuff goes into
like a free port somewhere.
So we have a free port
in our first episode
because we're like, we are
kind of paralleling real world
stuff.
We're just making it awesome.
But and trying to not be
completely [INAUDIBLE]..
But it is actually the
path that this stuff takes,
which is, it will go to a
free port, which is a, like a,
you know, somewhere in
Geneva or something.
It's a place where the stuff
comes in, it's not taxed.
No one actually
knows what's there.
There's literally like,
billions and billions
of dollars of art--
STEVEN SCAIA: It's a
Swiss bank for stuff.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: Yes.
And then that stuff
will come out like,
10 years from now
when the heat is off.
And it will end up on the walls
of a very wealthy person's
house or in a museum.
And you know, so it's
like, there's not just
like one bad guy in that story.
There's a lot of bad guys.
Because if someone wasn't
paying for that stuff, then ISIS
wouldn't be using it
to fund killing people.
And so, wherever we
are in the world,
or whatever the
season is, it's always
this like intersection of people
doing really bad things-- they
could be criminal networks,
they could be terrorists.
And then how that ends up in
places of wealth and privilege.
And how like, they
completely ignore the fact
that the other end of this,
there's a lot of bodies there.
And then our people are
following that trail.
So we're in dangerous places.
But we're also in tuxedos.
STEVEN SCAIA: And also
we embrace that too,
where not every rich
person is a good person.
Not every mobster
is a bad person.
And that's part of the
fun of the show too,
of like, as we build
out the treasure
squad as the season
goes on, it's
unlikely friends and foes
you wouldn't necessarily
see coming.
JOSH LANZET: I think there's
another question over here.
SPEAKER 7: Yeah, I have
a question for Matt.
Is there ever tension between
how you want to write the show,
or what you want to write
about, and like what
isn't necessary to promote
a good blockbuster TV show?
MATTHEW FEDERMAN:
I wouldn't say--
because I think we both have
pretty, pretty broadcast
sensibilities.
I think the biggest
tension between us
is generally a, like once
we figure out, OK, this
is the story we're
telling, it becomes just
about knowing what is possible.
Because I'm not where he is.
And so, I might think,
like, OK, well we
can do this whole thing.
And then he's
like, yeah we don't
have that location anymore.
We lost this thing.
We have to-- you know?
And then, so sometimes,
he wants to cut a scene.
And I'm like, that
scene is important
for the entire season.
We can't cut that scene.
But where will you be near,
and we can rewrite the scene
to fit the place
you're going to be at?
So our issue is
more generally like
where the writing
meets the production.
But in terms of
vision of the show,
we're pretty much like--
you know, if he is on set
and somebody is doing something,
I'm sure there's moments
where he has a thought of,
Matt would not like if
you said that that way.
And I will be in the room and
someone will pitch a thing.
And I'm like, I'm
fine with this story.
But right now, I am
having like, some
referred rage from another
place that's entering my body.
And I think it's like,
Steve is perceiving
that this story is boring.
And so we now need
to do something to,
like, you know,
juice this thing.
Because you know--
STEVEN SCAIA: It's a
good-- it's a good--
because we've known
each other for so long
and have worked
together for so long,
we are a good check and balance
against us too, of like,
we like a lot of the same stuff.
But there's also stuff that
I like that he doesn't like
and vice versa.
So it helps us be
like, as long as we're
in the Venn diagram of
shit we think is awesome,
we know we're generally
in the right zone.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: Right,
and like, for instance,
for pop culture references,
I am less interested in them
except insofar as
they reveal character
or they reveal like, how
these two people would
connect to each other.
But if when shows do references
just so the audience is like,
oh, they're doing
that thing I know.
And it's like, well, you
don't really earn that moment.
But so there's times
where we have--
we have some big moments
in the show where
there is a pop culture reference
happening right at that moment.
But what that moment
is about is like,
these two people have now
connected with each other.
And now they're speaking
the same language.
And so that's where
like, sometimes they'll
be a reference that I'm like,
this feels very like, in 10
years, no one's going to know
what this moment means anymore.
Because it's totally
dependent on a reference
to understand why
we're seeing it.
And so I'm like, it needs to
work on its own inherently.
And then, on top
of that, it can now
be awesome because someone's
like, oh, from that movie
I love.
JOSH LANZET: Were
there-- oh, we've
got another one over here.
SPEAKER 8: Hi.
So you were talking about
how people don't make
treasure hunter shows anymore.
Other than this.
And I think part of
the reason for that
is that they're very
steeped in this kind
of like, pre
colonialist, like we just
go and take stuff and
put it in our museums.
And similarly--
and on top of that
now, we have the
whole ISIS aspect.
And shows which have--
shows which mention
ISIS tend to make people
look like who look like me
into terrorists or victims.
So the question is, do you
spend a lot of time thinking
about how to subvert
those expectations?
Cause, I mean, literally
everything does this.
So I'm wondering if--
STEVEN SCAIA: Yeah
I mean, that's
absolutely a big part of how we
thought about the show, which
is, when we go to places
around the world--
like there's an episode that
takes place in Casablanca.
And the cops are good cops.
And they're trying to
help us solve a problem.
It's not that it's white
people going to a place
and saving them.
It's everybody working together
because we believe in sort
of the global family of it all.
Where there are lots of people
from all over the world.
Some people are good,
some people are bad.
It's not even about
governments necessarily.
It's about individuals.
And so I think, even just like,
looking at the two of them
and seeing how
different they could be.
But they work together
and they're a great team.
And that's the core of the show.
And I think that spills out
for the rest of the show too.
Where we don't just have all
the white people are good
and all the not
white people are bad.
There are good and bad
people all across the world
at every step of the way.
And so we moved very consciously
away from our bad guy
being an evil terrorist,
but more-- and also
try to make Oded Fehr
not be handsome dude
with amazing hair.
SOFIA PERNAS: And Lexi's
character is Egyptian.
She was raised Muslim.
And we say that in the show.
I'm actually Muslim.
And so it was an
interesting convergence
of characters and real life.
But yeah, and so the bad guy
of our show killed my father.
I'm not giving anything
away, because we
say this in the trailer.
Just saying.
But so it's sort of
like, there's no like,
the bad guy is the Muslim.
And that's the narrative that we
are going on for seven seasons.
It's not-- that's
not what this at all.
STEVEN SCAIA: And that thought
started in the writers room
where we had a diverse set of
writers from all over the world
as well.
Because we wanted to have
that unique perspective that
isn't two guys who,
you know, live in LA.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN:
Well the story Steve
was telling earlier
about the refugee camp,
it came from two of our
writers were born in Iran
and then fled in the
revolution and were refugees
at a certain point.
And they had pitched a
story, a Casablanca story,
which to me, was like the
perfect merging of the pop
culture and the show,
which was, you know,
he was like, I don't know if
you guys think of it this way.
But to us, Casablanca
is a refugee story.
And I was like, it's funny.
I've never thought
of it that way.
I've only thought of it
as like, a love story
or I've thought about the Nazis.
But they had a very
particular view of it.
And so they wanted to do this
story where our treasure hunt
intersects with Casablanca.
And a lot of the
Casablanca-ness of that movie
is pervading the episode.
You know, organically
throughout the story is saying,
but also, they wanted
to go to a refugee camp
and they wanted to have
our characters have
to like, basically take
refuge because the cops are
after them.
It's a whole thing.
But the point is
that, we really wanted
to tell that story because
especially for, you know,
a CBS audience,
which is probably
like the most unlikely
audience to watch--
or a lot of the things that you
would say are issues, maybe,
you know, it's a place where
you've seen those issues.
And we thought, well it
would be great to have
our characters go there and
really humanize that situation.
And then, because it's our show
and it's a fun roller coaster,
we set it on a beach so it
kind of looks attractive.
But like, the issues that
they're talking about
are like, they don't
have enough money.
You know, but they take
these strangers in,
cause they're like, listen.
This is a place for people
that don't have a home.
And we're going to
take you in tonight
and we're going to protect you.
STEVEN SCAIA: And another
big part of the show
is, it's about culture identity.
So when you go-- we go to
someplace in the world,
we want to learn
about that place.
And so there is the
moment in the trailer
where the pyramid blows up.
And you could look at that
purely from like the Roland
Emmerich spectacle of it all
where this thing happens,
and, oh, isn't
that cool visually?
But for us, it actually
ripples throughout the show.
Because it is about the
culture identity of this symbol
for these people.
And we had a lot of long
conversations about it.
We didn't just blow it
up to be controversial.
We blew it up because we wanted
that to be a thing that people
could keep coming back to
throughout the show of, no.
That is what
happens when someone
who does not respect the culture
of places does this thing.
And it was a great way to get
people who wouldn't necessarily
want to help us on our
adventure behind us
because you could just say, hey.
You know that thing
at the pyramids?
That guy we're looking
for, he did that,
and he is doing this to
your culture right now.
And we all need to work together
because he took something
from all of us.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: Yeah, so we
were like, basing it on Palmyra
and the Buddhist statues that
were blown up by ISIS and stuff
like that.
Like, when we were thinking
about who is this guy?
What is he doing?
Why is he doing it?
We're trying to use
real world analogs
to everything that's happening.
And, you know, when that's--
and then, interestingly,
we were talking
about how when the Notre
Dame fire happened,
and like around the world,
there was a sense of mourning
of like, this thing
has been there like,
longer than our country.
And you know, I
mean, it's a thing
that you think of
as being permanent.
STEVEN SCAIA: It's
not just the church.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: Right.
It's not just a church.
And it means things
to people that
aren't even of that religion.
It has a greater
meaning than that.
And how the world can come
together in moments like that.
And so we wanted to have
that represented in the show.
And then also, when Lexi's
character is after revenge,
and Danny's after some
form of redemption.
But in the end, there's
also this thing of like,
if we do this right,
we can kind of
bring these people
back together again
and start a process of healing.
Because we have found
this cultural treasure
that's been missing
all these years.
And we can bring it
back to the people.
So the first part
of your question of
like, taking things
from that region.
Like, the classic
line of our genre
is, that belongs in a museum.
And so it's interesting to make
the show in, at the time, 2016,
where it was like, actually,
that's not the right statement
anymore.
Like we've moved on from--
we don't actually think that's
the right answer anymore.
And if you go to
places like Greece
where so much of the stuff
was taken out of there.
And now they have
a museum that's
at the base of the Parthenon?
Parthenon, right?
Yeah.
And they have all of these
blank spots on the walls where--
and they have written in, this
is what's supposed to be here.
It's in this museum in America.
This is what's
supposed to be here.
It's in this museum in Germany.
This is what-- and like,
and what they basically
said to the world
is, you guys said
that we couldn't take
care of our stuff.
Now we've built this
really nice museum.
Why are you not giving
us our stuff back?
We built it so it
should be in its home.
And it's a refrain you hear
several times in the season
is, that belongs
back in its home.
We don't talk about it
being in a museum anymore.
We talk about going back to the
people, you know, of the place
where it was taken.
JOSH LANZET: So I know that
we're running out of time.
So I just want to ask
you one final question
before we let you guys go.
Looking forward from--
I would love to hear
from each of you, what
are you most excited
for everybody
to see in Season 1 of
"Blood and Treasure?"
Without giving too much away.
SOFIA PERNAS: I'm
most excited to see
how, the sort of pages
they take from each other's
books, Lexi and Danny.
About how they, you know, in
a lot of these two handers
in these network shows,
you have two people that
are working together that
are living side by side
and learning from each other.
But they never really learn
anything from each other.
They just remain stubbornly
and rigidly themselves,
which is not real life.
I mean, how many times
do your best friends
that you'll start to adopt
certain mannerisms that they do
or certain ways that they laugh
or shrug or move their body?
And I think that's what
I'm most excited about.
What Lexi learns from
Danny and vice versa.
MATT BARR: Sort of like
commenting on that,
saying that, what I really
love most about the script
was the dynamic between these
two and that kind of push pull.
It's so fun as an
audience to watch that.
And it has to be written right.
And these guys really
did it, you know?
And I think, rather, just the
movies and shows that I grew up
on that really did that
most effectively to me
were, well they were
hits, but they also,
you know, they're the
things that stick with me.
And I think that they threaded
that needle really well.
With these two guys from
different worlds and yet
somehow they, you know, they
exist in the same space.
And I'll be damned if they
don't, you know, work.
MATTHEW FEDERMAN: Yeah I
mean, I love those answers.
And I feel like
adding to that, I
think this 13 episodes
tells a whole story.
And so we're not
asking any questions
that we're not going to
answer within the 13 episodes.
And then, hopefully
we'll have more stories
to tell in the future with these
same characters going forward.
So to me, I think the way I
want people to go on the journey
and then see the way
it all comes together
and see how like, every
line mattered and everything
that was going on.
It was all part of one big
story that we're telling.
So at the end of
the 13, it hopefully
as a big emotional
impact of like,
oh this wasn't just a show
about like people running
around the world
punching people.
There was a lot more going on
there than what it looked like.
STEVEN SCAIA: And
I think for me, it
is just being excited to share
the adventure that we all
went on together.
From the very beginning when
we were in rooms pitching this
to people, but to us standing
in the middle of nowhere
and Tangier or Morocco
or that day in Venice.
And to be able to share the
amazing adventure that we
had where we became friends.
And now family.
And wanting to share
that with everybody else,
because the show's a lot of fun.
But it's also
optimistic, and the kind
of thing you could
all-- the whole family
could sit down and watch.
And I think I've been missing
that on TV for a while.
And I'm excited for people
to be able to see it.
JOSH LANZET: That's awesome.
Well guys, give a round of
applause for Matthew Federman,
Sofia Pernas, Matt
Barr, Stephen Scaia.
Thank you guys so much.
And thank you.
[APPLAUSE]